what's happening reject nation
I'm Greg Alva I'm John we're gonna watch
a patron video requests a day one of our
reward tiers whatever video you request
we must definitely do maybe one time it
wasn't a reaction no one could take it
twice but today it's another reaction
and that it comes from JN Valente the
man from Portugal who we've been trying
to get at google hangout with going with
since the beginning of time yet never
really gets back to us on time I feel
like he's a little bit shy which is
funny as I looked up his name this
Portuguese Valente means brave and
valiant and yet I feel like you're
feeling a little too shy to talk to us
use that bravery dude I really want to
see your face hear your voice because
Jan you've been one of our top pledges
for the longest time you barely asked
for anything I just want to have one
thing from you one additional thing is
just to hear your voice see your face
but if you don't want it that's cool
totally get it anyway he wants us to
watch this video the voice Portugal
Fernando Daniel we were young the Adele
song I'm assuming is what this is let's
let's check this out music you know
you're guaranteed to keep monetization
on a reaction video when there's music
involved Mo's death
[Music]
who's this boy who's this guy that's it
that's it
intense judging faces
this [ __ ] right here no not yet
before I see one more chair now we'll
see well sick
[Music]
exactly what she said you look like the
movie
you soon ready made a dick for man said
the boy
[Music]
he's gonna do it like a second before
just to go I'm just [ __ ] around
[Music]
right through that second episode of
black hair
[Music]
waiting for it
[Music]
we were
[Applause]
[Music]
these are such serious judges oh yeah
you never seen voice I've never I always
play this stuff up like or the chairs
can turn they're all like look at their
faces when they're watching him Wow
I wonder which I hope he went with the
last judge though I hope is one of those
twists where they like dry out the
deliberation process things like you
know why you took the most time but but
when you turned around you know you sure
about it so I'm going with you man
wonder how you must be a singer and then
do that
you got that one guy turn around
how do you not focus on the fact that
you have not heard that go off yeah burn
that you got to push your voice that
much further because that's all I be
thinking about what hasn't he turned
around what trick do I need to pull out
of my repertoire right now these other
two turn around right away what's going
on with this one guy one notes all it
took and this guy through most of the
song I feel like he was just doing that
to [ __ ] him maybe if I just waited out
those his voice will start to crack
let's see if he can really perform under
the pressure
yeah I was watching that guy and I was
like I bet he's waiting for that one
truly impeccable note or or vocal Tambor
or something especially when the like
one or two judges turn around
immediately that always inspires the
other to kind of be like maybe maybe not
a little too fast about this one yeah
well maybe you just really like Adele
heard the song and you wanted to see
this guy do a good karaoke version first
note comes up and you're like okay we're
all shocked that this is not a woman
singing Adele and it sounds like the
dudes probably got a good voice so just
hit that button right yeah like I feel
like yeah that contrast probably hit the
first two buttons anyway I feel like
they were a little too impulsive I mean
good for him I'm the worst judge of
character it's like I can tell when a
voice is terrible but sometimes the
voice is okay and I'm like
great la-la-land four examples one also
I mean you never know what the rest of
the episode was like yeah things and
they'll play up tensions where they're
you know other places and stuff you know
there's just love hello yeah at least
the one guy who took forever in servers
like that episode of black Mary the
second episode yeah with Daniel cool
Ouya and your cool Ouya embracing her
egg I mean good for him that was
beautiful that was beautiful it's a good
performing for the adele version i've
never heard it as i'm sexist ah good
good sexist in a right direction yeah JN
thanks for recommending that dude feel
like such boys portugal people are the
best out of them all I've never been a
big fan of the voice I don't like
judging shows
I don't yeah I'm here for those kinds of
shows I like the conceit of the voice
but that's about as far as it goes these
people who turn around a watch how much
of [ __ ] just enjoy it
critical moment they're sculpting their
team and I do I already have one of
these voices in my season or what you
know good for this guy all right well
thanks Jan you're a beautiful man I'm
sure you got a beautiful voice yourself
because you are always recommending
people from the voice yeah what are you
gonna turn chairs man I can't wait to
see that day I can't wait to see that
day just that handsome smile of yours
you sexy son of a B hey reject nation
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation if you haven't already click that
notification about the subscribe button
suck and check us out on patreon
full-length TV show reactions music
video coverage weekly Q&A is would love
to have you become a patron eject today
I believe I can fly